today on the matt walsh show the lgbt
netflix employees finally held their big
walk out yesterday to protest dave
chappelle and biological science only it
wasn't big just a small assortment of
people gathered for the demonstration
many on the right think that the
pathetic turnout was a failure and an
embarrassment for the left but i think
they're missing the point completely
we'll talk about that also the state
department celebrates national pronouns
day which is a thing now and donald
trump launches his own social media
platform is it on its way to wild
success or doom to failure plus the wnba
holds a parade in chicago yesterday and
you have to see the footage to really
appreciate it in our daily cancellation
i must cancel a republican candidate for
a political ad
you got to be careful watching as it may
cause a fatal case of the cringe we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
so yesterday after much media build up
an extraordinary hype a small collection
of lgbt netflix employees and their
supporters rallied outside of netflix
headquarters in protest of a comedy
special a few dozen people showed up
with a ratio of about three reporters to
every one protester it was reminiscent
of a joe biden rally both in terms of
crowd size and demographic
netflix itself has over 12 000 employees
of those 12 000 maybe 12 participated in
the walkout and those 12 had significant
support from not only the media but
hollywood various trans and trans
affirming celebrities released
statements and
videos throwing their weight behind the
protesters elliot page
formerly ellen page the wachowski
sisters formerly the wachowski brothers
wanda sykes formerly wanda sykes all
along with many other celebrities to
voice their support for the netflix
employees who were offended because dave
chappelle said that women have vaginas
there were more
obscure supporters on the scene as well
the daily beast gives us this story uh
quote comedian seven graham who is
intersex trans mask non-binary and uses
he they pronouns was in attendance of
the protest telling the daily beast they
felt the special crossed a line
quote i actually found myself crying
watching this special because it says
some very difficult very painful very
untrue things about who trans people are
graham said this special will be used by
people to fuel that transphobia that has
a very real world effect for trans
people as soon as i heard that trans
employees were speaking out and amazing
activists like ashley marie preston were
stepping up and organizing this
demonstration i knew that i had to go
fellow protester nick bewick uh agreed
says i was angry for days and i'm a fan
of dave chappelle i've been a fan since
2003 i've seen every single one of his
episodes i've seen every single special
sticks and stones kind of touched upon a
few things but it didn't really bother
me as bad
this seemed gratuitously aimed at us and
it wasn't funny it was gratuitously mean
it was gratuitously not funny it was
just self-glorification
self-masturbation i'm rich and famous
let me spew out all the things that i
think as if he was some sort of messiah
i think he got it twisted
so many people worship him and he's so
out of touch
yeah who do you think you are dave
chappelle giving your opinion like that
who do you think you are some some some
kind of messiah
you must have a messianic complex if you
would dare give your opinion
or tell jokes at a comedy special
see i'm trying as hard as i can to
picture
a professed comedian
sitting in his living room watching a
dave chappelle stand up special and
weeping
and i'm just having trouble conjuring
that image
we have to keep in mind that
the people in this assembly are shall we
say
special and so for example just to put
an image with the lining let me play a
clip of one of the protesters explaining
why he or they or whatever
showed up on wednesday watch this yeah
my name is david huggard i'm a
non-binary individual i also go by the
persona of eureka o'hara which has been
debuted on rupaul's drag race uh season
9 10 all-star six and hbo's we're here
david
d-a-v-i-d-h-u-g-g-a-r-d and then eureka
e-u-r-e-k-a-o-h-a-r-a
amazing so i mean first i mean like why
is it so important to be out here today
yeah i know it's important to be out
here today because we have to stand in
solidarity with each other obviously uh
ashley marie preston is a great advocate
and a huge sister of mine um also a
trans woman as a non-binary person we as
trans people and non-binary people
aren't getting visibility or respect in
the entertainment industry to begin with
and to have something like dave
chappelle special not be noted that it's
it's promoting discrimination and hate
conversation is very um hurtful to the
activism and the cause that we're trying
to progress ourselves in the industry
well it's good to see brian stelter
getting involved in the community but
remember
this is someone we're supposed to listen
to and take seriously eureka o'hara
deserves our attention and our respect
also remember they're not visible enough
even though 14 of them walked around
carrying signs for an hour and they made
it into the headlines of every major
news publication
but still not visible enough
and we need to make we need to make sure
we're not having hate conversations says
mr eureka
so we progressed past hate speech
and now it's hate conversation
some conversations themselves are
hateful to simply talk about certain
subjects is now an act of hate
that's what the activists are trying to
tell us
and it explains why they responded
violently to a quote-unquote counter
protester who showed up yesterday with a
provocative and offensive sign that said
we like dave and jokes are funny
that may seem like the most innocuous
and innocent statement ever written on a
sign in the whole history of signs
but that's not how the lgbt activists
viewed it let's see how they responded
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's my
i'm just here to say
that jokes are funny people
damn
funny guys
i love james
i don't know why all the violence
i don't know
okay
so to recap he stood there peacefully
with a sign that said jokes are funny
they accosted him his sign apart
started shouting that he had a weapon
and uh which is a great thing to do
because there are cops all around and
they're shouting he has a weapon
i mean you know as far as they're
concerned they'd be fine getting the guy
killed they don't care
and that really is true by the way
they're shouting he's got a weapon
because he's holding the stick that the
sign was attached to that they just
destroyed and if a cop pulled out a gun
and just shot him there on the spot
they'd be happy
they really would be and then they got
in his face and they tried to shove him
you know out of the protest but don't
worry the media made sure to report this
incident fairly here's variety um here's
their headline
at times the netflix walkout situation
threatened to devolve as counter
protesters pushed against trans speakers
that's the media's framing doing
everything they can as always to earn
the enemy of the people moniker
that uh that trump gave them now
let's think about
the privilege on display here
the lgbt people at this protest
belong to the most pampered coddled
uh celebrated elevated
and disproportionately visible
demographic in america
some of them apparently also work for
netflix one of the richest and most
powerful corporations in the world
they live in silicon valley employed by
a fortune 500 company they are applauded
and worshiped just for existing they are
the very definition of privilege and yet
they pretend to be victimized over a
comedy special
one guy tells one joke they don't like
and it's a national emergency everybody
can bow before them lay palms before
their feet as they walk follow them
around cheering and fawning over them
and if one person just one says anything
mildly critical or makes a joke at their
expense they will collapse into a puddle
and demand an fbi investigation and
they'll get it
they'll get what they want because they
always do
and that's why the small size of the
protest
is not an embarrassment for them
i mean we can make fun of it we can
laugh it off
but they aren't ashamed
why should they be ashamed the crowd uh
the crowd size
is is a symbol of power the crowd
displays its power by being small
think about it if you could go by
yourself
and stand outside of a major
corporation's headquarters with a sign
demanding that they take some sort of
action at your behest and it worked
and you got what you wanted
would that image of you standing there
alone a crowd of one be embarrassing
no quite the opposite
we console ourselves with reassurances
that these people are in the minority
and they are
but they run everything and they get
exactly what they want every single time
and it's not so reassuring when you look
at it like that
so i hope you can see by now um and if
you listen to this show you must see it
because i'm hammering on the point all
the time but i hope you can see that
this stuff is not just about gender
or sexuality
it's certainly not about dave chappelle
what we're living through is a giant
social experiment it's the biggest
social experiment in world history
and what the experimenters are trying to
find out is this
can a vocal and powerful minority alter
the majority's perception of reality not
simply influence their opinions or
convince them to adopt a new position
but fundamentally change their very
perception of reality itself
primarily by screaming threatening and
cajoling them
can the human instinct for
self-preservation the natural desire to
avoid confrontation can these be
exploited to such an extent that
millions or billions of people can be
made to not only tacitly tolerate a
bizarre idea but to actually over time
believe it themselves
you know if they
in the minority
act like a statement of basic truth is
wildly offensive dangerous harmful it's
going to get people killed
if they do that
and they do it often enough can they not
only convince millions of people to keep
quiet but eventually can they convince
those timid masses to really believe
that the truth is offensive and that it
being offensive makes it somehow not
actually true
that's the experiment
we're all living through right now
those are the questions that the social
engineers are trying to answer and so
far
sad to say
the answer for many people has been yes
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as i'll tell you about in a second
we are stranded here in a in a hotel in
grand rapids and uh that's a problem
because that means it's another night
away from
uh my wife and children but more
importantly
my my pillow um you know it's very hard
for me to sleep without my pillow and
that's why if you have not tried my
pillow yet you've gotta try you'll get
the best sleep of your of your life and
you can get great discounts right now on
all my pillow products that's the good
news if you go to mypillow.com right now
and click on the radio listener special
get deep discounts on my pillows
mattress toppers towels and so much more
for example my pillow is offering a buy
one get one free offer on giza dream bed
sheets they are top quality sheets that
you will love all my pillow products
come with a 60-day money back guarantee
and a 10-year warranty go to
mypillar.com click on the radio listener
square for buy one get one free offers
on the giza sheets and use promo code
dailywire at checkout or call
1-800-651-1148 that's mypillow.com and
enter dailywire or call
1-800-651-1148 and tell them dailywire
sent you that's 1-800-651-1148
you know guys i uh i really hate being
proved right that's one of the themes of
this show i'm proved right so often but
i wish it wasn't this way i don't want
to be right about the things that i said
i just am
and that happened again this week when i
discussed a few days ago you know the
issue of pilots on planes who who give
their passengers too much information
remember i said you know you you don't
need to tell us what's going on up there
just get us from point a to point b
none of the people on the plane none of
the passengers we don't know how it
works any additional information you
give us that
because we lack
the base of knowledge to process and
understand that information it's just
going to add to our anxiety and our
fears so
as if to prove me right as if to
illustrate my point we were at the
airport yesterday
in grand rapids getting ready to leave
and head home but today as you can see
we're still we're still in hotel we're
still here in grand rapids and that's
because the plane broke
unfortunately it broke before we we
boarded it
and we couldn't get another flight that
night because apparently grand rapids is
in the middle of the amazon rainforest
and there's one flight coming and
leaving per month or something so we had
to cancel the flight entirely we had to
rebook on another airline for today and
by the way the only direct flight that
we could find
was on an airline called allegiant which
i don't even think i'd ever heard of
before yesterday
and so we'll be boarding that flight
today and i made the mistake of looking
up allegiant safety record this morning
and it's it's not great is all i can say
uh it's just it's not good allegiant is
a budget airline below spirit
okay
allegiant planes they don't even have
wings they actually just roll down the
windows and they have their passenger
the passengers stick their arms out and
flap up and down you know
it's like the modern version of the
roman galley ship
flight attendants walk up and down the
aisle with whips flap faster flap
anyway um that's all beside the point
the point is that while we were at the
gate before we rebooked
the gate agent on the intercom
got on the intercom and said this and
this is a direct quote i swear to you
this is what he said
he said
sorry for the delay ladies and gentlemen
we're having mechanical issues with the
plane they're going to shut the plane
off and turn it back on
and hope the issue disappears that is
exactly what he said
as if the plane runs on windows 98 he
might as well have said that you know
they're going to hit control alt delete
just see what happens
turn it off and back on again
maybe next pull out the cartridge and
blow on it i don't know
how is that the solution that that's the
way i fix all technical issues but i'm a
[ __ ] that can't actually be the way the
world works
that can't be what commercial
airline pilots do
you're telling me that they're just as
confused and mystified as the rest of us
they're looking at the problem and going
i got nothing i don't know just turn it
off turn on again we'll see
these planes are up in the air and
parent apparently nobody knows they're
up in the air and no one knows how they
got there or what they're doing
that's that's the way i'm interpreting
this no one has any idea what's going on
hope the issue disappears
would wouldn't you want to know where
the issue went
and if it's likely to return
is that what the pilots are doing up in
that mysterious little room the co-pilot
says to the pilot hey you know there's
there's a blinking red light here with a
skull and crossbones and it's saying
danger danger what should we do about it
yeah i don't know turn it off back on
again
sure it'll be fine
my god we're doomed we are doomed
no no one that's that's the lesson kids
you have to understand this this is this
is a one of the realities of life that
you realize as an adult and you're
horrified when you realize it but no one
has any idea
what they're doing
anywhere with anything everyone is
clueless and we're just walking around
blind and that is life
all right uh so
speaking of clueless the state
department has an important message for
the people of the earth
and here's the message they tweeted out
yesterday
it says today on international pronouns
day
we share why many people list pronouns
on their email and social media profiles
read more here and then
if you click and it goes to
share.america.gov so this is a
government website
shared by the state department
and there's a whole article about about
pronouns
it says i'll read some of it it says in
the united states it's becoming
increasingly common for people to share
their pronouns third person personal
pronouns are used to describe a person
or people in english american grammar
as the subject as the object or the
possessive
these pronouns include the
gender-neutral they them theirs words
that traditionally refer to a plural
number but that today are used by some
individuals who identify as gender
non-binary or who prefer not to share
gender information other pronouns
include the feminine she her hers and
the masculine he him his
some people are pioneering
gender-neutral pronouns such as
zee-zer-zers
this is a government website this is the
state department
putting z
zers
out into the world officially endorsing
it
um
and then uh i don't need to keep reading
this i can't keep reading it i'll have
i'll i'll have an aneurysm if i do
i have to tell you when i when i
when i encounter this kind of this kind
of thing
of course my first reaction is just
sheer embarrassment
that this is the u.s state department
ostensibly supposed to represent us
represent the united states of america
and this is what they're exporting out
into the world and this is what this is
this is this is a
an intentional
i mean this goes beyond merely pandering
to the left
this is the religion that our government
right now is exporting into the world
this is the ideology
it's a religion of self-creation of
self-worship
um
a religion that rejects truth as a
category
rejects truth as a category
not just has a different idea about
truth or has a different idea about what
is true and what isn't
but rejects it as a tragic as a category
there is no truth
what is truth as pontius pilate said
in a way is the punches pilot religion
now what is truth the truth is whatever
you make it whatever you decide that it
is
and this is what the united states of
america this is what they want the
united states of america to represent
on earth
we used to talk about how we wanted the
u.s to represent freedom to all the
peoples of the earth
perhaps we should have been more
specific
because now we represent freedom from
reality
freedom from truth freedom from moral
decency
freedom from even biological realities
biological science
freedom from our own bodies
that's what we represent but
when i see this along with feeling
embarrassed
i also can't help but uh every time
it makes me mad
and angry
at the right
i mean yeah at the left but it's
it's it's it's fruitless it's pointless
it's redundant at this point to be angry
at the left of course i am but
even more so at the right
because
maybe ultimately there was there was
nothing we could have done about about
this about this this slide into madness
even if we had all been on the ball
about it from the beginning
it may have still ended up this way i
don't know
but the fact is that so many people on
the right for years were just whistling
past the graveyard with this stuff
and they would say about the pronoun
issue oh it's just who cares about that
just call people what they want why why
are you so focused on this why are you
talking about it this is a small issue
this is a sideshow this is a distraction
for years and years that's what i heard
i don't hear it anymore
i mean i've been on these issues as you
know
from day one
and for years
the criticism i would get from people on
the right is this these issues don't
matter it does it doesn't make a
difference it's this is superficial
this is a phase it'll go away why are
you why are you paying attention to it
just don't pay attention to it and it'll
go away
right like jurassic park with the t-rex
don't move it its vision is based on
movement stand there still and it will
walk past you
for years that's what i heard
and i don't hear it anymore
because even the dumbest most clueless
most oblivious
uh muddled brained people on the right
even they
even those even the ones in that
category are starting to see that oh wow
this is a big deal
this is a war on truth
i mean we are marching into total lunacy
and madness
and there is no end in sight and it oh
it it actually matters
who who would have thought
but it's kind of too late now
like if this is your wake-up call that
the state department
is celebrating international pronouns
day
and talking about z zimzers
you know if you thought this was a phase
and it would just go away it's a silly
childhood thing and it would you know
and now and now the state department
is promoting it and if this is your
wake-up call we'll say it's too late
uh okay
from abc news
it says
silenced by many major platforms former
president donald trump is launching his
own social media app trump media and
technology group and digital world
acquisition group which is already
listed on the nasdaq have entered into a
merger to form a new company chaired by
the former president according to a
press release
trump says the group will form a rival
to the liberal media consortium
uh in which
uh its first step will be launching a
new social media platform called
truth
social
and truth is all in caps i'm not sure if
that's supposed to be an acronym or
something but a better version will be
available to invited guests in november
according to release trump said in a
statement we live in a world where the
taliban has a huge presence on twitter
yet your favorite american president has
been silenced
according to the release the company was
formed using a special purpose
acquisition company
uh yadda yadda etcetera so truth truth
social is going to be the um
going to be the
the platform
and it'll join you know parlor and gab
and some of the other
uh
alternative social media platforms
founded by people on the right
now i
i don't know if it'll be successful or
not
i hope it is
right i think it would be great to have
uh to have competition
for twitter and facebook and instagram
and and to have a platform where you
know there actually is free speech and
um it's not controlled by ideologues on
the left
and all of that kind of stuff i mean i i
think it'll be great so i would root for
it
but i'm very skeptical
um
about trump's social media platform i'm
skeptical of all the right-wing you know
social media platforms
and there are three reasons
one is that
so far you know most of these
alternative platforms
there's no innovation like there's
nothing really
interesting happening technically
speaking
with the sites and you go to it and the
sites look like and they feel like
knockoffs
this is the problem
that
on on the on the right
we've had in that we we've had in many
areas of the culture where we're trying
to come up with responses to what
they're doing on the left
but we end up just imitating
what they're doing on the left
and and then you and then you the result
is something that's
it's just it's not as interesting it's
not as cool to to to the average uh user
or someone in the audience
look at
this has been the fatal flaw of
christian rock music
since its inception
that there really isn't any innovation
going on it's just let's try to sound
like that kind of music over there we're
going to base our whole style and
everything off of that we're going to be
the
you know we're going to be the christian
version of that
and so in these right-wing media
platforms social media platforms
i i guess they go into it saying let's
be the right-wing version of twitter
and you do that you're already doomed
because you're not going to be a better
twitter than twitter
twitter's been doing this for
over a decade they've got billions and
billions of dollars they've been
extremely successful you're not going to
be a better twitter than twitter you
have to do something completely
different
and um usually that's not the way it
goes and so it's not a success the other
problem is that
you know echo chambers are boring
i've used some of these platforms and
it's kind of like i'm there everybody
agrees with me and it's kind of like i
i i guess it's it's nice to be around
people that you agree with but
especially someone like me i like to mix
it up a little bit i like to know that
i'm gonna say something and people who
don't agree with me are going to see it
and you you take that element out of it
and it's not nearly as fun and then but
then the third here's the big thing
this is the big and most important thing
and this is why i say the conservatives
say oh i'm done with twitter i'm done
with facebook i'm i'm i'm done i'm
logging off
and then they ask me why why haven't you
why are you still using it
well because
i can use twitter
to try and
drive the conversation
and to and to bring attention to issues
and to ideas and to things that the
media does wants to bury
so that that's a function of twitter
and i've used it that way successfully
many times many people on the right have
to drive the conversation to bring
things to the forefront
that would not be at the forefront look
at what's happening with school boards
across the country right now
do you think that this would be
happening
without
without the the the unwitting help of
twitter and facebook
no it wouldn't be
do you think we could have organized a
movement like that on um you know
parlor or one of these right-wing
social media platforms no
because you're you're only you're with
your own people doesn't have
doesn't have the same cultural purchase
it's very insular
and so you can do that you can actually
have
talk about social media influencers you
can actually have influence by using
these platforms
um and driving cultural conversations
and that just doesn't you know there are
no
influencers on these other right-wing
platforms there isn't i mean there are
influencers who are influencers on on
the major platforms and then they go
over there
but those platforms haven't um haven't
birthed their own
influencers
so
that's a problem it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't try but i i think it's
important to have those issues in mind
and try to address those problems with
whatever platform you're trying to
develop
all right so let's go where else are we
okay
this is great um
the wnba team chicago sky won the wnba
championship a few days ago
now normally
this is where you might expect that i'm
gonna make a bunch of jokes about how
nobody watches the wnba
and how you know i didn't even know that
the championship happened
or even that the wnba had championships
at all i figured they probably didn't
keep score you know
but um
i'm not saying that i'm not going to
joke about that and i'm not going to
make any comments about the chicago sky
and how it sounds like a brand of girly
11 wine that they serve at baby showers
i'm not going to make any comments like
that
you know i'm not going to talk about how
the dunk contest of the wnba all-star
game is more like horseshoes
where they score based on who gets the
closest um
i'm not doing that
those are jokes i'm not making because
i'm not a rude person and i'm not a
sexist
and they play their hearts out
and before you claim that nobody goes to
the games consider the fact that most of
these players have parents and they have
aunts and uncles and i'm sure their
families are supportive and they come to
these games
okay and that really adds up
so anyway all that to lead into this uh
let's play this this is uh footage of
the chicago cloud victory parade i saw
this footage yesterday and i really felt
it's it's the saddest thing i've ever
seen
imagine throwing a parade
in the middle of downtown chicago and
nobody shows up
you thought that that joe biden rallies
were the saddest thing but this somehow
tops even that i think joe biden could
have could have a parade he could throw
a parade and he would probably get a
better turnout
but this is i'm not making fun of this
is not me making fun of it i i'm this is
me expressing sympathy i mean they this
is so sad they should build a monument
in the middle of chicago to this parade
where future generations can come and
weep and wail before it
it is it's a tragedy we will all
remember the day
october 20th
2021 where were you when the chicago sky
victory parade took place and nobody
came
uh
poor poor ladies but you know
you see that kind of turn out they have
a championship no one even knows the
championship pitch championship happened
but
wnba players they should be paid the
same as uh as as nba players they should
get the same just
right they get they get 15 people to
their games they got two people at the
parade
both just happened to be walking their
dogs and they stopped and looked at it
and they should be paid exactly the same
as nba players keep that in mind because
that that is uh that's what equity and
inclusion is all about
all right
let's uh so i wanted to play i wanted to
not play but i want to show you this as
well this is from christopher lamb he's
a rome correspondent for uh media called
the tablet
uh reporting on
a sermon or a speech delivered by pope
francis
and pope francis is was giving some some
credit some props to the george floyd
the blm protesters
al always very topical and on the ball
as pope francis and so he's chiming in
on this you know two years later and he
says of the blm
movement in response to george floyd
where there was rioting and violence all
across the country terrorizing cities
for six months
he says
this movement did not pass by on the
other side of the road when it saw the
injury to human dignity caused by an
abuse of power
yes the blm movement
is concerned with the uh with protecting
the dignity of the human person
that's right pope francis
and that's what that's really what they
were standing for i i think is is human
dignity
that's why you you know run into a cvs
and
steal everything you can run out with an
arm full of merchandise and burn the
place down on your way out that's that's
your way of saying
that human dignity and human life is
very important
i really think this pope's pontificate
has been it's been good and useful
in one sense only and how it's served to
sort of symbolize and encapsulate
um all of the problems with the church
in modern times it kind of it all can be
boiled down to this
not that pope francis is causing all of
those problems because these problems um
predate him
and in many ways he is a people he is
certainly more a symptom of of the
problems than a cause of them
but he does he does kind of symbolize
that it's ev everything that's wrong
with the church
in in in the west in modern times
with church leadership
hopelessly out of touch
uh afraid to take real moral stands on
issues that matter
not at all
in in connection with you know the lives
of real human beings
the people that come and sit in the pews
not concerned about not not aware of of
the issues that these people are dealing
with every single day
now this is not the case in
in every church
but in a great many of them
you know i've had this experience many
times
attending churches
all across the country you know in many
of the states i've visited
and
often times you go into those churches
and you sit down in the pews
and um
it it should be
it should for one thing be a respite
from all of the madness out in the
culture because you're coming in there
after a week
another week spent in this decaying
uh
culture
another week spent as a parent trying to
shield your kids from the corruption and
the perversion
um that threatens them and threatens
their innocence and you come in kind of
battered and broken and you sit down in
the pew and it should be
for one a respite and a rest from all of
that
and it should be inspiring and
motivating
um
preparing you to to go back to battle
because that's what it is as christians
in the culture we are we are in in a
state of constant spiritual battle
and that's not new
i mean that's
that has always been the case we've
known that you read it in the gospels
this is what we're promised is that we
will be
um in in a battle until until the end
times when the battle is finally won and
over and that's the good thing is that
we've we've read the last page of the
book we know how the story ends but in
the meantime
um it is going to be a real a real
battle
um
but that battle has has taken a you know
an extra profound i think a toll on us
in recent times
and we're losing the battle culturally
so we're sort of the guerrilla warriors
now we're not on the most powerful side
uh we don't have all of these levers of
power so we're more this has become a
kind of spiritual guerrilla warfare and
the point is it in in that environment
given what we're dealing with you go
into church and you want
to hear the priest or the pastor get up
there and you want to know that he
understands
that that's the environment you are in
as the faithful
and you want to hear something that
speaks to that and that's useful and
that will equip you spiritually for the
next week of battles
and very often you don't hear any of
that
you hear uh something that sounds like
you know it
at best it sounds like a
a seminar on teamwork that you might
hear from an hr representative at your
work
or or you hear more of the madness and
lunacy that you already got in the
culture
it's not the case everywhere there are
churches where there's that are
certainly an exception but unfortunately
they are an exception okay finally so
katie couric has uh she's been
out of the spotlight for for a while uh
but apparently she's still alive and
kicking which is good
and she's got a book coming out and it's
i guess it's a tell-all
memoir where she throws all of her
former colleagues under the bus which is
always a fun time
and she was giving she was she was doing
an interview on nbc or abc or whatever
it was
and i thought it was interesting that
first she talks about
sexism in the news industry and how she
she encountered a lot of sexism and the
how sexism oppresses and suppresses
women
and you know it deprives them of
opportunities and everything so you knew
that there was going to be that claim
but then at another point in this
interview and i guess in the book as
well
she talks about her own
as a woman her own relationship with her
female colleagues
and um
how how far she went to help them and
apparently not very far at all listen to
this
well let's talk about that because you
talked openly about female mentorship
you said you were you had your own
insecurities you know you felt like you
had to protect your turf those were your
words yeah are you i mean do you regret
that now i mean what's your perspective
on it now you said um i was less
welcoming when charismatic female
correspondents entered my spear there
were only a few coveted spots for women
i felt like i had to protect my turf
yeah i mean i think that's brutally
honest you know i think that i have
mentored scores of women
many of who still work on this show and
in the control room hi ladies but um you
know i think that when there are very
few jobs for women and men are making
decisions not necessarily based on
you know the right
criteria that sometimes you do get
insecure and sometimes you do get
territorial i think it's human nature i
think anyone in a high profile physician
in a coveted spot and i think even
outside the tv industry both women and
men
have felt that occasionally i just was
honest enough to admit it i think and to
be clear did you ever actively try to
sabotage never female never
never never i think i just wish that
maybe i had extended myself more and
shown people the rope but ropes a little
bit more but i think when people
are outwardly kind of vying for your job
it is hard to be generous i think i i
love that she
she says in the book that well you know
i didn't really want to help out
charismatic and talented females i felt
threatened by them but i did mentor a
lot of other women like the ones in the
control room
hi ladies
of course saying that well they're not
charismatic and talented so they didn't
threaten me at all
um
but this is
of course she tries to disperse the
blame out to and you always love when
people do this they say well yeah i did
this but everyone does this
no not everyone there are people who are
who are perfectly willing to mentor
others and don't feel threatened by
everybody else in their industry that's
kind of a you thing but
it it does show
this um
reality that that does go beyond katie
couric
but that doesn't often enter the
conversation we talk about the
resistance allegedly that women face in
the corporate world or in media or
whatever industry
and we're told that um they don't get
the same opportunities and that they you
know they have this this extra these
extra roadblocks that are thrown in
front of them
and that is always attributed to sexism
as katie kirk does in the book and
earlier in the interview but then she
says that she herself
as a woman felt threatened by other
women and didn't want to help them out
which you
in honest moments you hear from women a
lot that
oftentimes
the most resistance
and the most hostility that they
experience at work is from other women
not from men
but katie kirk wants to have it both
ways and she said yeah it's sexism but
at the same time
yeah what it's it's a sexist industry
and so i i guess i made my way to the
top and uh
i don't want to help anyone else get
there there are only a few spots that's
the way she rationalizes it but i think
the truth is pretty obvious okay let's
now read the comments
[Music]
[Music]
never gets old those sweet sweet sounds
of the sweet baby gang anthem it never
gets old not to me anyway
gareth says
with matt traveling so much i'm extra
careful to return my cart just in case
he's lurking in the parking lot
somewhere and that's good that's fear
that's what i want you to feel i want
you to feel like there's a there is an
eye watching over you whatever watchful
eye
watching
uh especially when you're in the parking
lot
and you know something there is even if
it's not me
god is watching
he sees every single shopping cart
you've ever left in the parking lot
and you will answer for that
in this life or the next so help me god
uh
daniel pack says
matt morningwire is the only podcast
that values your time and the truth
me
but i'm listening to your podcast right
now well yeah but i guess as we've
established in many ads we do on the
show you should be listening to this
podcast there are better podcasts the
morning wire values your time and the
truth i don't value i value the truth
but i don't value your time so i don't i
don't have both i do care about the
truth
but your time is not important to me
which is why i'll ramble on you know
about shopping carts or about urinals
for 17 minutes
uh so there are a better podcast
the jordan um the jordan the uh
the jordan show my guy jordan another
another great show that you could listen
to
be cozy says i can't believe matt's
talking about zocs zookeepers of color
but ignoring the larger marginalized
bizac community
i guess i'll be black indigenous
zookeepers of color
yeah i guess i should have mentioned
them as well
and when you say that i realized that
both bipac and bizac
sound like
maybe an antidepressant
or a star trek character one or the
other
um pet usb says
hair's looking a little rowdy today matt
that hotel life is rough i guess first
of all stop body shaming second of all
um this is one of the
sacrifices i have to make it's one of
the
trials and tribulations that i face
is that i don't uh they don't send a
stylus and a makeup artist with me and
so i gotta make do i gotta rough it much
you know i really feel connected in when
i'm traveling
to the pioneers on the oregon trail um
the the pioneers you know
forging west
uh
having nothing but their clothes on
their back and whatever they could fit
into their wagons and i feel i i feel
connected to that because
i have to travel with
no makeup artist
no stylist
it's tough but i get through it
another comment says i actually do enjoy
the food at hooters i know i sound like
the guy who said the guys who say they
read playboy for the articles but the
wings at hooters are above average
certainly better than applebee's or
chili's well
you know that i'm not a hater of
applebee's or chili's i've said that
before
i think
it's a solid option you know what you're
gonna get i don't have this this elitist
mentality about chain restaurants
however
still as far as the wings go
saying hooters has better wings than
applebee's or chili's that's like saying
it's like walking into somebody's
apartment and saying oh wow this is way
nicer than living in a tent made out of
trash bags under a bridge
um
daniel says matt doesn't realize he's a
celebrity now if i saw him in a bathroom
i'd totally say hi and ask for an
autograph
obviously not before he washed his hands
and then i would um sue you for sexual
harassment because that is sexual
harassment and that that i think is
where we need to go with this
conversation as it evolves
that's um speaking to another man in a
restroom
is a form of i i think it's a form of
sexual harassment
and uh
at least that is how i'm going to
interpret it
right now from now on which really makes
it much weirder and more awkward
uh mike says
matt's missing a trick the only thing to
do with a commercial flight is to sleep
through the whole horrible experience
can't imagine anything more certain
to snoozify than an airline info pack
challenge yourself to get past page
three awake um yeah i can't sleep on
planes i don't understand the people
that do that
i can't sleep
uh
in airports like i can't see you see
people on airports that are sprawled out
on the ground
i mean i was an airplane at this
national airport the other day on our
way here
before we got stuck and stranded here
there were people
there there weren't a lot of seats in
the national airport it's kind of
cramped there not the greatest airport i
have to say i like nashville but the
airport could use some work and there
are people sprawled out just on the
ground in the hallway
sleeping
and you
you're going to you are going to allow
yourself
to sink into unconsciousness
around
hordes of strangers people you don't
know
and you're going to
have have your body laying there
unconscious i i can't i can't do that
that that requires a certain amount of
trust
in
in other people who you don't know that
i just don't have
and finally john says the one time i was
sitting in the exit row on a plane i
actually read the info just out of
curiosity about what it was
matt's being self-conscious come on man
grow a pair and stop worrying about
people's opinions like a little girl i i
think i think it's the other way around
as men we you know this is this is a
stereotype but it's true we don't we
don't read directions
we don't ask for directions i mean that
parts we have gps now so we don't have
shame about asking gps for directions
but um as far as like reading
instructions or assembling something you
get something from ikea we you know we
always say well we could just do it
ourselves so
that's that's the way i look at it with
the exit row i don't know what i'm
supposed to do but if the plane goes
down first of all we're all probably
going to die anyway so
it will be a non-issue
but if somehow we do survive i'll figure
it out
when we're in the moment
and then we'll all die because of that
because i'm unprepared so that's that's
the way a true man approaches this i
think well we know that cryptocurrency
has been rapidly increasing in
popularity and for good reason uh but if
you're like me and you find the whole
thing a little bit bewildering and
confusing you don't know where to start
um well then you need to get alto crypto
ira with ulta crypto ira you can trade
crypto like bitcoin and avoid or defer
the taxes get into investing in crypto
and do it in a tax advantage retirement
account altos crypto ira is the easy way
to get crypto into an ira you can trade
all you want without the tax headache
and they make it very simple very easy
for you to create an account in just a
few minutes
and uh not a lot of red tape or hoops
you gotta jump through you create the
account you can invest with as little as
ten dollars there are no setup fees
nothing like that you get secure trading
24 7 through altos into integration with
coinbase there are more than 80 coins
available including bitcoin uh cardano
many other coins if you want some sushi
swap with your bitcoin no problem alto
has that covered they've got everything
you need so open an alto crypto ira
account with as little as ten dollars
just go to alto ira dot com slash matt
that's a l t o i r a dot com slash matt
go to alto ira dot com slash matt and of
course
as we were just talking about you
deserve nothing less than the facts with
your morning cup of coffee and we're
here to supply them i'm not here to
supply them uh the morning wire's here
to supply them not only has it been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its release it's the only daily
podcast that values
not just the truth but also your time in
and out in 15 minutes you get everything
you need and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know we need your help to keep the
facts trending towards number one so
subscribe and start listening to morning
wire and apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts and leave a five-star
review if you like what you hear now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
some of you will not like the daily
cancellation today it's it's okay if you
don't like it you're banned from the
show of course if you refuse to applaud
everything that i do and say but we can
part ways and ways on amicable terms
even so and the reason you might not
like it is that today is going to be
another case of friendly fire i have to
criticize
someone who is ostensibly on my side and
there are those on my side who don't
approve of criticism which is pointed
back in this direction they say that we
should all be on the same team and we
should focus our critical energy outward
not inward
but anybody who's ever actually been on
a team knows that some of the harshest
and most useful criticism you'll receive
is from your teammates
after all they're the ones who
want you to improve they have a stake in
your improvement that's the way teams
work a team which refuses to engage in
self-criticism is a team that loses
and so i say all of that talking about
teams
but the subject of my criticism today is
a politician and i hesitate really to
say that any politician is on my team at
least i won't trust that any politician
is a real teammate until they've proven
it and after they've proven it
they have to continue to prove it
and prove it some more every day
a politician has to earn my trust and
even after they've earned it i still
don't trust them so with all that in
mind
we turn to michelle fiore she is a
republican candidate for governor in
nevada
now i don't know anything about michelle
fiore
she might make a tremendous governor or
she might not i don't know
all i know is what i learned in the ad
that i'm about to play
i certainly agree with the positions she
lays out in the ad i like the positions
i hate everything else about the ad
take a look
[Music]
i'm michelle fiore and i'm running for
governor
i spent my whole life fighting the
establishment i was the first female
majority leader in nevada assembly and
one of the first electeds to endorse
donald j trump and you better believe i
was attacked for it
[Music]
[Applause]
washington post called me a gun-toting
calendar girl and politico magazine said
i was the lady trump and i don't care
we need outsiders fighters not the same
old boring moderate compromise lou
blazer politicians
let's start with a three shot plan
fan vaccine mandates ban critical race
theory and stop voter fraud
the joe biden administration is coming
after me
i'm michelle fiore and i'm ready for the
fight
[Applause]
now admittedly it does seem that she
keeps abreast of the issues but aside
from that i mean this is everything i
hate about gop blue collates it's like
the greatest hits of republican cringe
she pulls up with a pickup truck with a
trump 2024 sticker on the back in fact
she mentioned trump
three times in a one-minute ad as if her
positive feelings about donald trump are
her primary qualification for the
governorship
and then we got the generic twangy
guitar riff in the background and she
struts through the desert in an
extremely impractical red dress and
leather jacket combination with the gun
strapped to her hip
she hits all the talking points that are
about as generic as the guitar riff did
you know she's an outsider and a fighter
and not the same old politician
fascinating a truly groundbreaking claim
i mean this is the first time i've ever
heard something like that in a political
ad
i should also mention that i've been
frozen in a cryogenic vault since 1732.
maybe that's why i've never heard it
michelle then pulls out um you know the
sidearm and shoots some beer bottles
though noticeably we don't actually see
her hitting the bottles the camera cuts
away right before the trigger press
and at the end her name comes up on the
screen
in flaming letters in a style that makes
you think her last name is fieri not
fiori
the idea behind an ad like this of
course is that it's supposed to make us
right wingers feel like she's one of us
she gets us she's down with the cause
but instead it just feels lame as hell
the very epitome of trying too hard and
the ultimate effect is the opposite of
what's intended
rather than feeling like she's one of us
it feels more like she's an outsider
uh you know not in the way she wants us
to think she's an outsider and it's
trying to sort of ape our style and
speech and mannerisms it feels like she
went to party city and picked up an
average joe or jane conservative costume
really it feels exactly as it is like
she paid a lot of money to some pr firm
so that someone who's never held a gun
or been inside a pickup truck could tell
her how to connect with people who do
live that way based on surveys and other
data points
truly i can't think of anything less
authentic
than a political ad that looks and
sounds like a truck commercial
watching it i half expected her to tell
us that she got the highest customer
satisfaction award from jd power and
associates that's how that's how
contrived it all seemed
from the ad i don't know who the real
michelle fiore is all i see is some
corny frankenstein constructed by a
focus group nothing real here
you might as well cut out all the
superfluous stuff and just stand in
front of the camera shouting guns trucks
freedom trump explosions trump fire
trump guitar
that's all the ad contains anyway the
rest is just connective tissue meant to
hold all the pandering and bumper
sticker slogan earring together
it's cheesy is what i'm trying to say
and it's fake and it's hollow and worst
of all it's patronizing
this is the kind of ad that i would make
if i was running for political office
and if i believe that my voting base was
comprised of shallow dim-witted easily
impressed morons
all gimmick no substance
now granted
one can only expect so much from a
political advertisement
but the problem is that the all gimmick
no substance thing that's all we've ever
gotten from the gop as a whole for 30
years
the ad is supposed to make me think that
michelle is different from your average
republican politician but instead it
puts her right in line with all the rest
of them because this is what they all do
this is what they all give us
if you want to impress me present
something that makes me think you're
something more than a pandering puppet
who thinks folksiness is an acceptable
substitute for authenticity
all of this
and we haven't even mentioned the worst
infraction
the beer bottle she shot or someone shot
were still full of beer
at least drink the beer before you
destroy the bottles for god's sake have
some respect
that alone is enough reason though there
are plenty more
to say to michelle fiore unfortunately
you are cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical directors austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show netflix
employees walk out to protest dave
chappelle special and the media gush
over them plus the biden administration
says they've got vaccines for your
five-year-old but your kid will still
need to mask that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen